goo
みなさんこんにちは
はいありがとうございます no 心理マーケターの岩本竹のれていますよろしくお
願いします
僕はこの地域でスーパーマーケットやショッピングセンター
電車とかバスといった生活に欠かせない事業を展開する会社でマーケティングという
仕事してますマーケティング皆さんあまりご存知ない方もいると思うので簡単にご説明
をしてきた
です僕がやっているマーケティングというのはお客様が欲しいものを欲しい時に
しっかり届けていくってことなんです
だから相手の立場で考えるということは絶対なわけでして
なぜ人がその行動をとるのか次に何を願っているのが何を期待してるのか2名に考えて
いることが必要なんです
僕はマーケティングを業務の大ハボスーパーマーケットで稼ぐてきました
でもマーケティングを始めた当初っていうのはなかなか成果が出ずに本当に悩んでたん
です
なぜかというと恥ずかしいんですけどね僕は相手の立場で考えるということが全く想像
できなかったんです
どういうことなんだ相手の立ちバッ
そんな思い悩んでいるときに
ふと昔あったアクシデント思い出したんです今から15年前
2000年の2月の26日でした
まだ生後まもない2ヶ月だった僕の長女が僕が運転する車で交通事故に遭って脳挫傷
犯されました
脳には大きく損傷を受けてしまった脳というのは1回
損傷すると治らない臓器なんです
でも僕は
そのことを信じたくなくて
彼女の様子を見ると
学習の能力明らかに手先指先のの左側の特に左側
運動機能が劣っていました
でもねそれを信じたくなくてその日から脳の勉強を独学でしていったんです
お医者さんじゃないから治療はできないけれど
の後の仕組みに応じたリハビリを行っていけば何とかなるんじゃないかと思ったんです
例えば
彼女の目の前でスプーを持つ模範演技をしてあげるんです
一個一個超えてやるんだよって目の中へ四角の中へ入れてあげて彼女に真似をさせる
サイクルをとってくんですすると彼女次第に真似をします成功と失敗の体験を何度も
繰り返してやがてそれはノウハウとなって彼女の中に脳の中に記憶
として宿るんですこの単純なサイクルは僕は15年間彼女と行ってきました
4つそうすると
本来は回復するはずのない脳がみるみるうちに回復していって脳波まあ安定していった
んです
その証拠に彼女今どうなっているかもともとは動かなかった手を使って両手を巧みに
操る
クラリネットの走者になっていてそして学力も向上して目標とする高校にも合格できた
んです
僕はねありがとうございます
6この奇跡を通じて彼女から学んだことがあった
それは
相手の立場で考えるということはあ
脳の立場で考えるということにほかならないということなんです
改めて僕はこの経験を整理してみたんです
用需要の絵本や学習の参考書を思い出してください
文字だけじゃなくて絵柄もふんだんに使ってあるのが知識や経験のない人のためにそれ
をイメージさせるために使っているんですそのことが何でかわかるようにそう
物事を理解するには視覚に入れてイメージをするところ14だから僕は彼女の前で模範
演技をしてあげたんですそのことで初めて気づくこと
もあればそれによって過去の経験と照らし合わせて
脳は行動判断をするということがあるんです
卒まで僕ら脳のメカニズムというのが情報を愛で入れてそして気力のフィルターにかけ
て行動を起こしていくんです
はもちろん資格でなくてもいいと思いますたとえ出すものに下がるいものの匂いを嗅ぐ
ものを味わう体験をすることによってイメージするということはとても大切なんです
僕はこれを早速マーケティングにかしてみましたすると僕のマーケティングには成果が
共になってきた今だからこそ
国内外のメディアに僕のプロジェクトを取り上げてもらって
そしてマーケティングの先生方からもよく頑張ってねって褒めてもらえだったんです
そんな僕が皆さんにお伝えしたいことはたった一つです
それは皆さんのアイデアを求めている人にしっかりと伝えていってほしい
その思いを込めて
脳の仕組みを活用したアイデアの伝え方をお伝えしたいと思います
先冒頭に僕のマーケティングは主にスーパーマーケットを使われたそんな話をしたと
思います
だから今日スーパーを舞台にして少しアイディアの伝え方
お客さんにどうやって相手を伝えているのかなぁなんてことをご紹介したいと思うん
です
スーパーだとアイディアをね商品と読み替えてください
な伝え方を並べ方って読み替えると
そのままし無比の並べ方になります
皆さん日頃がースーパーマーケットでしょう評価をお客様だと思うんです
今日は僕販売者の立場で話をします
そうするとね両方の立場が理解できると思う
お店に今度行ったときにお店って本当は何オススメしたいのかなぁなんていうことを
よくわかってもらえると思うんです
ところでスーパー行くと皆さん試食なんて経験したことがあると思うんですね
あそこにはいっぱい人が集まってきますでしょ
ネっこれって何でだと思います特に焼肉のたれを焼いてお肉10試合ていると香りが
蔓延してそして24絵がついて
主食をすると味を体験するじゃないですかこれってね
味とか匂いとか香織っていうのは実はん
脳の中に感情を司る大脳辺縁系っていう分野があるんです
ここに情報が美味しいよって届くからあそこにお客さんが群がってくれます
でも主食を毎日やってるとスーパーも結構コストが大変で物理的には場所が限られるの
でこれを毎日やってられない
でも日常茶飯チキチンとお客さんなアイディアを伝えていくためには何かをしなきゃ
いけない
その r ディアの伝え方それはね
商品の陳列なんですつまり商品の並べ方なんです
この陳列に
脳の仕組みを取り入れたらどうなるんだろうこれを皆さんと一緒に振り替えていきたい
とおもいます
皆さんスーパーマーケットには
何万点の商品が並んでいるかご存知ですか
だいたいね約3万点並んでいると言われています
そのうちの3分の2は皆さんよくご存知のメジャーブランドと言われている
企業口の中にある定番の商品ですでも残りの3分の1が大事
僕らの想いそしてアイディアがぎっしり詰まったおすすめ商品が並んでいるんです
僕はこのおすすめ商品の魅力をいかにお客様に伝えるかどうかがスーパーの成功の
分かれ道だと思っていますだからこの魅力を僕はお客様の脳の中に伝えようと思ったん
ですこれはもちろん人間がもの
のでものを目で見てそして究極のフィルターにかけた行動するという脳のメカニズムを
僕は知ってるからやろうと思ったんです
でもこれを後押ししたことがあるんです
それはある来店客のアンケートでした
スーパーマーケットに来店されるお客様の約78%もの人が
お店に来る前に今日買う商品を決めて
意外ですね
これってねどういうことかというと今日またご飯つかなきゃいけないのみたいなめんど
くさいみたいな気持ちで悩みながら帰りもの生きているということです
でもおかしいんですよレジに並んでいるお客さんの姿を見ると
籠の中でしっかり商品入ってるんですっ現時的におかしいと思いませんか
3万点もある商品のなか
にスーパーではだいたい平均で11店11商品買うというのはだいたい平均値です
3番商品の中から10逸品を短時間で選んでいくなんて人間技じゃないんです
だからなんでその消費を選んだんですかって僕をお客さんに聞いてたんです
そしたらねこそって言うんです
たまたま目に入ったからっ
たまたま目に入ったということだと思ったんですけどよくよく考えればそのたまたま目
に入った場所を見つけてそこにおすすめ商品を置いていくのは僕らのアイディアが
もっともっと伝わるんじゃないかそう考えたんです
だから僕はマーケティングの先生方に相談しました
たらみんな冷たかったそんな奇跡みたいなこと考えてないでとっととデータ分析でもし
てくださいと言われました
それは無理はないんですよ3万商品の中から11商品を選ぶ
成功確率は0点03%ですこんなね奇跡丁寧語と誰も信じませんで動くは長女から
教わったんですね奇跡が起きるってだから諦めたくなかった
すぐに
脳の波形を測定できそして人間の視線を感知できる特殊メガネを作っているメーカー
さんに相談しました
なぜならばお客さん亭
お買い物の最中動向を見ているんだろうそれを知りたかったんです
そしてちょっとはずかしめな女がでも用意していただいてお客さんにそれをつけてお
きゃお買い物してもらったんです
大変ご迷惑かけたんじゃないかなと思うんですけど
そうしたらね
とうとう見つけてしまったんです
名によって
ある並べ方をしておくと大注目してくれるおすすめ商品に視線が釘付けになる
陳列方法これを発見したんです
僕はこれうれしくなっていろんなところでお話をするようになりましたが今日は皆さん
とその決定的な瞬間をこの場で共有したいと思っています
皆さん見てください
これね鍋つゆの売り場を見てもらったです鍋すよねー
この色がついているところこれは特殊カメラでお客様みたところを色付けています
みどりきいろああ彼の順番でお客さんが見ている時間が長くなる
そう思ってくださいっいっぱい商品が並んでますけど皆さん気づくところないですか
ないないですか
からこれねこうするとわかるかもしれない
これ明るく色の行けるところがお客さんが見ているところです
ほとんど見てませんよね
並べたしたもかわいそうだなと思うんですけどおちかれさんみたいな
これもう一個線を引くと特徴が出るんですここで左と右
どっちをお客さん多く見てます
どうですか
どっち右右たみぎの人が多そうですねはいありがとうございます
ちょっと若干今左といった方あまりを吐くを離れていただいてですね
はっはいこれあの右が正解です
僕ら人間の脳というのはどうやらどうやら
右側の情報を取りやすいっていうふうにできているようなんですそのことを証明した
スライド
よねこれだけだとつまらないから僕もう行く売り場に仕掛けしているんです
なぜかというと人間は記憶で行動を起こす
そういう動物だから
つまりスーパーで記憶と置き換えると定番商品なんです
鍋ついの定番商品を実はこの売り場の左側に僕を見せる人に黙って並び回だった
そしてその右側におすすめ商品並べたんです
どういうことかっていうとねさっき左側といったしても落ち込まないでほしいって言っ
たらそういうこと
間に左側も見てますよねお客さん
これ定番商品記憶をよりどころにしてお客さん行動を示してる証拠なんです
とっても大切なことはこれを左側から右側に数
て視線を移動しておすすめ商品を見ている
その陳列がなされていることなんです磯つまり僕らのアイディア
おすすめ商品の魅力をお客様に伝えるには定番商品の右側に並べるということが大事な
んです
僕はこの仕組みを発見して切りな売り場はねちょっとねいじってみたんです
そしたら
今まで売れなかった商品が昨年の7.6倍も売れるようになった
この本当に嬉しくて嬉しくて仕方がなくてあるカンファレンスでね
話ししちゃったんですよ
女性が上司に怒られたんですけど
また今日も話しちゃってますけどね
そしたらね大阪でスーパーマーケットやってる方がいて
で原さんというものすごく優秀な方なんですがお魚の売り場で困ってたそうなんです
彼のシール力とものすごい神聖なお魚をそろえてくるから美味しいんです
彼のお魚売り場では
鯖が人気の商品だったんですよ
だから定番商品ですよね言うならば
でもどうしてもねうなぎ好きなんですからうなぎを売りたい
確かに美味しいです
そうしたらからどうしたと思いますか
左側にサーバを置いてそして右側に
う投げを言っ
前年の200%もれる方です
これで奇跡ですよ
でもこれが皆さん
相手の立場で考えるってことなんです
脳の立場で考えた証拠なんです
皆さんが持っているアイデアを求めている人が世の中にたくさんいる世界中タックせる
んです
そして皆さんが考えた商品が欲しい人は世の中にいっぱいいます
でも脳の仕組みや陳列一つで
その商品に会えないなんていうことはなんて不幸なことなんだろうって思うんです
だからもっともっといっぱい方法があると思うだから国や地域や環境でもそれは差が
あるでしょう
だからどんどん研究してほしいんですだからどんどんノウハウを活用してほしいですで
も大切なことは僕ら人間のコーデは全てノーからメッセージされているということを
もし皆さんが持っている間を世に広め
共有していくためには
もう一度思い出して欲しい
僕ら午後の構造を
人間は物を目で3件イメージに変え
そして記憶のフィルターに変えてかけて
行動起こしたく
視覚だけでなくてもいい触れたりにおいをかいだり味を体験してそしてイメージを
いっぱいくらました上で人間は行動に出るんです
このことを忘れないでいただきたいと思います
そして最後になりましたが僕からメッセージがあります
これは15年間娘から教わったこと
皆さんのアイデアを人や社会の役に立てたいならば心の中に刻んでほしいことがあり
ます
それは
皆さんがアイディアを求めている人のために考えてほしいです
それには資格がある
その愛でを伝えるべき資格がある人の心の中には
あの人を救いたいっていう強い心たちがあるかどうかなんです
脳は邪な気持ちを認めようとしません
皆さんのアイデアを良い披露目そして世界のみんなが笑顔になりますように
皆さんのアイディアを求めている
そんな人との出会いがさらにつながって
今日のお話が
今後の世界発展に貢献できることをお祈りして今日の話を終わりたいと思います
脳から心へ届く ita の伝え方
no 心理マーケットで岩本だけ形でしたありがとうございます